fans of Aquaman have been on the edge of
their seats waiting for the lost kingdom
to come out it has been hit with an
array of delays onset drama and
controversy that nearly broke the
internet but is still looking to Prevail
once it hits the box office this winter
with whispers about a potential Trilogy
let's get into it Jason mima's Aquaman
costume was highly anticipated and for a
good reason the design for the lost
kingdom costume sticks pretty closely to
the original comic book design even
though the color design is different
sorry my CS are so big that you can't
zip it it's problem I have at home while
a lot of people were skeptical in the
beginning about the original orange and
green suit the costume designers managed
to pull it off pretty nicely feel like
Patrick squeezy right
now the most notable switch up for the
lost kingdom design was the darker more
mysterious version of the hero's
original suit the updated costume
features a lot less protective spikes a
more squared shape of over the chest and
a more notable sense of armor around the
legs and five armor plates on each thigh
the shoulder pieces are also separated
which gives the suit a fresh distinctive
look there's also the gloves the
original suit had a lot of spiked finger
protectives while the new version only
showcases three what do you think about
the switch there were a ton of delays
and false starts when this movie was
being made mostly because of covid and
an array of online chatter surrounding
the film film's cast this was around the
time when Johnny Depp and Amber herd
were having their high-profile
defamation trial so there was a lot of
controversy surrounding Amber herd at
this time according to notes from her
therapist that fans of Johnny Depp paid
to have released from Court the Aquaman
set was rather hostile for her with an
allegedly intoxicated Jason mimoa
dressing up like Johnny Depp and pushing
to get her cut from the film it's
unclear whether her drastically reduced
role was because of her infamy or
because of her lack of chemistry with
Jason Mamoa director James Juan had to
learn new techniques of keeping calm to
stay grounded quote I've had to learn to
be more Zen in dealing with all the
noise around me for sure I'm a pretty
private person I don't get on social
media and have fights but it's difficult
because this narrative has emerged that
is not the reality there were also about
7 Days of re-shoot which isn't uncommon
for a film of this size
but it took so long because it ended up
being spread out to accommodate all the
actors's busy schedules regardless of
all the delays and cast drama the door
is definitely still open for a Trilogy
in the future James Juan though he's
directed a wide array of films has said
that he would love to direct a third
film in the Aquaman franchise because
he's never gotten to do something like
that in his career yet quote I'd be open
to doing another Aquaman if I got the
same Freedom I've had on these first two
I'm not sure what direction gun and
saffron are going in though so who knows
I've learned to Never Say Never he's
also learn to accept that regardless of
what he wants in a movie the films will
never turn out the way he initially
envisioned them something you might not
know is that Jason mimoa has always
wanted to be a writer he even wrote a
50-page treatment for Aquaman in the
lost kingdom why did you want to be on
that side of it because actors get
treated so much better than writers he
wanted to give it a try because he feels
so connected to the character he's
literally been playing him for the last
12 years now but even so it was one of
the most vulnerable moments of his
career like I said he's always wanted to
be a writer but it wasn't something that
he's even gotten to explore throughout
all of his years working as an actor
you're going to put your heart out there
but I'm like doing this is what I would
would love to do the training for the
movie was unsurprisingly extensive
throughout the course of filming which
lasted around 6 months you got to lift
and pick up heavy things and put them
down yeah there was a lot of physical
preparation for all the actors mostly to
make sure they didn't hurt themselves
while filming scenes so because you put
those suits on 40 lbs on top of what
already is 260 it's any movement it's
it's just added weight during all this
prep swim training lifting and meal
prepping Jason mimoa and Aquaman have
gotten pretty intertwined you could say
he has been in Aquaman training mode for
the past 12 years I do swim pretty fast
Aquaman in the lost kingdom regardless
of all delays online rumors and drama
that may have been thrown into the mix
is clearly backed by a dedicated cast
and crew stunning wardrobes and Jason
mima's personal perspective on his
longest played character what's your
favorite behind the scenes
moment